nous l'avions tellement aimé que nous
l'avons adopté claudia larochelle
nouvelle chroniqueuse livre au
téléjournal 18h bonsoir à vous que le
dimanche sans patrie alors millénium
canine beaucoup parlé c'est un phénomène
où j'ai demandé de le lire
alost marathon bon ça reprend les
personnages principaux bien sûr lisbeth
est toujours là avec les autres est de
plus en plus désirer vous remettez nous
asseoir yquem lundquist est toujours là
aussi le journaliste voilà je peux vous
dire que c'était effectivement c'est un
phénomène c'est important qu'on en parle
parce que c'est un phénomène qui était
aussi fort aussi puissant dans
militaires par exemple que cinq ans
nuance de gris récemment ou par exemple
harry potter donc forte attendue
c'est vrai si fort parce que ''des avait
de la gueule la lager prince cet homme
là c'est un journaliste fort populaire
fort que huit vit à stockholm en suède
et on l'approché quelques années pour
qu'ils reprennent donc la série bon
évidemment beaucoup de stress beaucoup
de pression il ne savait pas trop dans
quoi il s'embarquait et effectivement il
le constater un peu à ses dépends parce
que toute une polémique là ça suscite
est vraiment une très grande controverse
autour de cette parution là une
controverse qui implique les ayants
droit
donc le père de stieg larsson l'auteur
de la trilogie 1 2 3 et son frère contre
la les pousse donc dû défendre ce
n'était pas sa femme ils étaient
ensemble et c'est pour ça qu'elle n'a
pas touché alors les gens n'ont pas de
droit aucun acquis et bien sûr choqué
quand ils me voient là le livre c'est
bon le livre il est bon il ya des gens
qui n'en remarque rompt pas j'ai des
gens qui vont boycotter justement ces
livres là tout un mouvement en suède qui
le boycotte pour ceux qui ont aimé milan
à meudon les trois premiers tomes bon il
y en a plusieurs qui vont apprécié parce
que c'est toujours aussi factuel on
parle d'un autre journaliste ici en 7
lager crans c'est un journaliste on
retrouve michael bombay on retrouve
aussi les bêtes
un autre personnage est ajoutée à cette
belle bande c france balder et on
s'attache très vite à bâle der kwast qui
est un peu étrange c'est un jour touche
étrangement oui toujours en pions on a
vraiment ni vraiment dans la suède grise
un peu froide c'est un geek et passionné
d'informatique et s'infiltre partout
notamment dans la haine et ça et il
quitte subitement le l'entreprise pour
laquelle il travaille et jour au
lendemain il disparaît et c'est là
qu'est michael blomkvist retrouve tourne
un peu dans ces view dans ses vieux
dossiers on lui donne ce mandat-là au
journal à millénium il repart faut dire
qu'il est très motivé il veut résoudre
l'énigme parce que on est dans la crise
des médias aussi non journal là on en
parle beaucoup c'est dans l'air du temps
on pense à tout ce qui s'y passe
actuellement avec les hackers dans le
milieu des médias dans l'espionnage
informatique on est là dans parle de
corruption énormément de choses
nouvelles aussi qu'on apprend puis c'est
fort c'est fort intéressant mais je dois
dire patrice c'est un peu un peu long
très bien on aurait aimé vous donner
plus de temps vous allez être là les
vendredis on va expliquer tout ça aux
gens en temps et lieu merci beaucoup
d'avoir lu ça en catastrophe pour oui ça
vaut la peine pour celui qui aime ça
merci claudia